[Music]
in Mahwah news oh that's you mom bra do
you think you've brought a brawl brawl
let her [ __ ] up another mom would ya
cuz some other kids kicking Tigers asses
you're like [ __ ] you and you got a star
fight it's gonna be in PT n [ __ ] yeah
baby
really I want to be [ __ ] involved oh
okay
what does PTA stand for I want to know
my parents were that involved I don't
know yeah I feel like P TAS are like the
type of people that do the the HOA
meetings yeah that's why to picture you
guys doing it submitted by cannibal
trees cannibal trees there's like venus
flytraps that's funny
I heard trees can communicate to each
other through their roots yup is that
sure that's [ __ ] yeah that's
communicate and then they [ __ ] battle
with roots - they [ __ ] root grapple
yeah yep there's some plants that kill
the other plants off so you have to be
selective of what flowers or whatever
you're getting cuz some will just take
over and kill us do man everything in
nature is so [ __ ] violent why it's
all about survival dude yeah people
don't know that [ __ ] I passed over
people there killing the other plant
homies yeah before two moms got into a
bloody brawl at a school bus stop make
sense oh bloody bronze because one of
the kids was bullying their kid yeah
alright well [ __ ] it that cheating
husband was sleeping with the other
husband I know you like dramas yeah I
thought I was like a blood mom and crap
mom Oh that'd be crazy dude I don't like
the way your kid where'd his
handkerchief know this happen in Florida
so there were these two moms at a school
bus stop and they had previously had
like some sort of like verbal
altercation Oh daddy I don't like each
other they like each other because one
mom told and so there was this one mom
that was yelling at these kids that were
not her kids and so this other mom
stepped in was like telling her
mind your own business I don't know what
she was saying don't be yelling at damke
the banjo works that's what started it
that's pretty good that's pretty
accurate that's when they started
fighting and then like one mom she had a
coffee mug for sure they brought the
coffee mug and they use both of them use
it as she that is ty Shh
the worst thing I've ever heard in my
life that's some hotel artemus kind of
[ __ ] right there you know I thought so
then like the Bert like the one of the
moms she went into the hospital she has
scratches and cuts all over her arms and
then the other one had to be airlifted
to a hospital because she had piece of
mug stuck in her neck oh she got it she
was going for the death kill dude kid
exactly that was like a pool of blood
all over the place like kids are taking
they're going to counseling because they
were trying to protect the kids because
one of the moms was yelling at the kids
so then they cut each other in front of
the kids I need to know what this fight
was about I just told you yeah it's like
don't yell at those oh that was the
reason yeah she's trying to be a [ __ ]
morale [ __ ] sauna what the [ __ ] okay
joke kids don't [ __ ] yell at okay
the yelling at the other kid that was
what first started like there an
altercation right the previous argument
now this one they're saying that it's
just about parenting so I don't know
what that means maybe one kid was going
wild and then she's like hey watch your
[ __ ] animals whoo or maybe one just
said you're a bad mom I feel like that
would trigger so many people right
wouldn't you be triggered if someone was
like you're a bad mom depends on who
says it like you give your kids soda
I'll show you guys one of the moms so
the mom that has brushed up on her on
her arms being interviewed
crazy it was self-defense over an
incident that made no sense and I put my
arm up like this and I went to run and
that's when she picked up the glass ran
at me and stabbed me she got this close
to my face nudged me with her nose and
when she nudged me with her nose it it
was her fist was going up so my fist
went up
when you're attacked it's fight or
flight and I did both I hit her and I
ran and then she got me twice afterwards
so do you regret anything about it I
forgot the whole incident there's no
reason it should ever happen that's
pretty cool the way that she looks and
the way that she speaks way different
yeah
and the altercation doesn't make any
sense because she's so composed so
interesting and I love her tattoo that
was a tribal art tattoo with elk horns
yeah that [ __ ] was interesting I'm
trying to think a point in my life where
I wasn't that pissed where I'm like
let's do this and like crack some [ __ ]
like ready to throw it out has anyone
ever [ __ ] with your friends or your
fiancee putting people [ __ ] with me I
don't only get mad but when people [ __ ]
with my friends that's when I get mad
yeah but I think it's just like warrants
like a nice sit-down conversation at
Starbucks you know like nothing's like
like there was this time I see it it was
like when me Bart and Joe this is like
when we just started our friendship like
six or seven years ago and we're at a
Korean barbecue and there's this [ __ ]
Korean guy screaming at like this other
dude at a KB BQ and the first thing I
thought I was like this was come on I'm
[ __ ] grab this bomb of smash over his
head and I got she was drunk he wasn't
knowing that's what I thought too yeah I
thought he was gonna start some [ __ ]
other I'm sitting on a weapon this chair
is gonna be awesome if I go if I smash
the base oh it was like Korean barbecue
but it was like this group of like older
Koreans just having a date and eating
together and having a blast and he was
like I'm Korean you're Japan and we're
gonna [ __ ] go to war and don't think
I kept saying no I'm Korean to you I'm
speaking to you in Korean yeah I know
it changes me multiple - yeah but it's
like one of the roommates well I was
like $8.99 spots so you know I was gonna
I am bad which one why cuz you ate too
much I just said you just Starbucks it
down
I'm just not about like actually
physically like getting mauled by glass
right yeah but some people don't even
yell so raging on people is still anger
no I like to yell what did they do
essentially my fiancee had one of his
top clients
okay visiting from freaking mother
freaking China okay and they wanted to
eat at this barbecue spot and this
barbecue spot is known for having like
it was a weekend - it's like a two-hour
long way so they were like he was like
he called me and he was like hey you
have no job you have no life go wait
there for them right so then I went I
waited two hours outside he's amazing
we're getting married waiting outside
his clients show up bigots seated and
then he's like oh by the way like why
don't we just eat there - like I'll meet
you there and then he came with a bunch
of his colleagues after work we all ate
and it was like two separate tables like
all the Chinese people here and then him
and his work people in me and this was
when I was under-21 pertinent to the
story and so we were like okay we went
up to three different servers told them
make sure whatever they're eating gets
paid on this company card do not let
them pay a penny
don't let the base [ __ ] okay cuz this
was the last day here in the US so my
fiance was like I got to pay for their
dinner they they charged them and then
they charged us and then they charged us
up for our food and they refused to let
go of the charges one I was literally on
the phone with the carribean owner and I
told her listen she was like threatening
to call the cops and sounds like you
call the cops because we ordered alcohol
I'm under 21 you did not check my ID so
call the [ __ ] cops like let's
do this
she was like okay then we'll refund it
back and then I was like okay and then
like all the server's knew about this
and like they were all giving me the
shadiest mother like they look like they
wanted to kill me because I feel like
she probably took it out on them like
she didn't sound like a nice person
so I'm just kidding I'm gonna get cut if
I go back but it was like such a good
barbecue
it was parts dog you could go to a
different one into third quarters if you
want to go dirty you service is so good
it's good if you want to go if you're
taking clients you don't think in the
condo condos like mid tier did it you
need to go to [ __ ] parks parks is the
[ __ ] it is really it's like one of those
here parts is [ __ ] but that's
probably what bass parts BBQ is like
[ __ ] prime ass [ __ ] but they're
jockeys they don't know what they want
all that's true and I dream about it
that would really know what a rolling
delegate yes service is on point
yeah see I've never been to the k-town
would been to but okay so here's the
thing like this is my theory about
k-town service right a lot of people go
there to drink club they're obnoxious
and they're stressed out way more than
all the other Korean neighborhoods in
the suburbs that's why the service is so
much better like if you go to roll in
found valley whatever I feel like Cape
Town is like you're just gonna get
[ __ ] up mean service yeah calm load
only he's not he's the one of the
investors he was like sigh is that the
one word like his faces alone yeah yeah
so he's like a [ __ ] I'm champion to
Korean barbecue you can't I just can't
go back and I miss her what do you think
memories go to [ __ ] augur she copped
tongue doing the same thing yeah unless
you cope chung is the same parent
company but they have but you want
things that you can't have yeah it just
tastes better that way it's forbidden
but I'm just scared that they're gonna
like spit in my food you're cooking it
anyway
like in the little side dishes or the
kimchi jjigae or the tendency gaze you
know just go to another one okay go to
point apart they've like open and
franchise now so that person is just
that for that store you just got to go
to a different one
Oh true I'm like kicked out of a 24-hour
in [ __ ] Sacramento but I can go to
another one 24-hour fitness why did you
take it down cuz I'm not the dude out in
our basketball dance when I was like 20
years old well it's because this guy so
we're playing ball long story short when
people get aggressive like on basketball
there's there's always one [ __ ] that
thinks that he's from the NBA yeah and
he's the worst [ __ ] basketball player
ever right so basically what happened
was I was just posting him up I was a
big dude 240 pounds of this when I was
weight training a lot so I just posted
month stars corner [ __ ] high swings at
elbow [ __ ] knocks me in my face and I
was like yo bro this isn't [ __ ] NBA
Jam cut that [ __ ] now what the [ __ ] are
you gonna do about it and the guy
[ __ ] shoves me I was like yo don't
[ __ ] touch me man I'm not being chill
and this is during the time I was a
pastor - I'm being chill I think I was
like do something and right when he said
that I snap and I just [ __ ] o'clock
and I clapping I fear the heart is
spirit and I mean I mean arguably so I'm
bleeding out of my [ __ ] nose you know
what I mean and so like I was still
trying to be chill and the guys like do
something and I just clocked them and
then after that we both got you
[Music]